♪
JEDEDIAH: ARE
JEDEDIAH: ARE WILL -- LET’S ASK
DR. NICOLE SAPHIER.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US AS
ALWAYS.
>> GOOD MORNING.
JED YESTERDAY IF YOU WOULDN’T
MIND SPEAKING TO THE EFFICACY OF
THE JOHNSON AND JOHNSON VACCINE
ALONG WITH THAT GOES A BIG
QUESTION WHICH PEOPLE ALWAYS ASK
IS WHICH ONE SHOULD I GET?
DO I HAVE A CHOICE?
AND HOW DOES THIS ALL PLAY OUT?
>> WELL, THERE IS A LOT OF
QUESTIONS GOING ON WITH THE VAC
SEEMS AND THE WILL VARIANTS,
JEDEDIAH.
I THINK IT’S IMPORTANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE VARIANTS BEFORE WE GET
INTO VACCINE EFFICACY.
VIRUSES MUTATE NATURALLY.
AND ACTUALLY IT’S COMPLETELY
DEPENDENT ON HUMAN BEHAVIOR.
THE HIGHER THE VIRAL
TRANSMISSION IN THE COMMUNITY,
THE MORE CHANCE HAD IT HAS TO
MUTATE.
WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE SO MANY
VARIANTS CIRCULATING THE GLOBE.
MANY ARE MORE CONTAGIOUS AND
CARRY A HIGHER VIRAL LOAD IN
PEOPLE.
CAN LEAD TO OVERWHELMED HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS AND ALSO INCREASED
DISEASE SEVERITY.
NOW, WHEN YOU TAKE AT THAT AND A
LOOK AT THE EFFICACY TRIALS
COMING OUT OF THESE VACCINES
PFIZER AND MODERNA HAD
INCREDIBLE OVER 90% EFFICACY
DURING LATE STAINING TRIALS AND
NOW JOHNSON AND JOHNSON HAS COME
OUT SAYING THEIR SINGLE DOSE
SHOT HAS HAD A 66% EFFICACY.
HOWEVER, WE CAN’T COMPARE THESE
APPLES TO APPLES, JEDEDIAH,
THAT’S BECAUSE THESE VACCINE
TRIALS WERE TON AT DIFFERENT
TIMES.
WHEN MODERNA AND PFIZER
UNDERWENT CLINICAL TRIAL THEY
HAD FAR FEWER VARIANTS
CIRCULATING AS OPPOSED TO
JOHNSON AND JOHNSON AND NOVA
VACCINATION AND ASTRAZENECA
CLINICAL TRIALS.
EVEN PFIZER AND MODERNA SAYING
SOME OF THESE VARIANTS ARE NOT
RESPONDING AS WELL TO THEIR
VACCINES.
THE GREAT NEWS THOUGH OUT OF
JOHNSON AND JOHNSON NOT ONLY IS
IT A SINGLE DOSE SHOT, EASIER TO
TRANSPORT AND ADMINISTER.
HOWEVER, THEY DID SHOW THAT
THERE IS 100 PERCENT EFFICACY IN
PREVENTING SEVERE DISEASE AFTER
ABOUT A MONTH AND A HALF.
THAT’S BIG NEWS.
AND SO WE HAVE TO KEEP THINGS IN
CONTEXT.
WE DON’T KNOW WHAT THE CURRENT
EFFICACY OF PFIZER AND MOW
TURNER THAT ARE IN LARGE SCALE
WITH THESE VARIANTS.
THEY WILL ALL PROBABLY BE
SIMILAR.
ANY VACCINE YOU CAN GET YOUR
HANDS ON AT THIS POINT IS THE
ONE YOU SHOULD BE GETTING.
JEDEDIAH: UM-HUH.
SO THERE IS A LOT OF CONCERN
ABOUT THESE DIFFERENT STRAINS WE
KEEP SEEING IN THE NEWS.
THERE IS NEW ONE FROM SOUTH
AFRICA THAT IS CONCERNING SOME.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT IT SO
FAR?
>> SO, B 1352, THE SOUTH AFRICA
CAN STRAIN HAS A SIMILAR
MUTATION TO ONE THAT’S ALSO
BEING FOLLOWED OUT OF BRAZIL
WHICH IS CALLED P 1.
THESE ARE THE VARIANTS THAT
WE’RE REALLY INTERESTED.
IN MANY VARIANTS OF CONCERN
CIRCULATING U.K. ONE.
A COUPLE ACTUALLY IN CALIFORNIA.
THOSE SEEM TON A BIT MORE HIGHLY
TRANSMISSIBLE AND THE VACCINES
SEEM TO BE CONFERRING IMMUNITY
TO THEM AS WELL AS PREVIOUS
INFECTION.
SOUTH AFRICA CAN SCRAPE, THE
BRAZILIAN STRAIN AS OF NOW, WE
ARE SHOWING SOME LAB DATA AND
ALSO CLINICAL TRIAL DATA THAT
THE VACCINES AND EVEN PREVIOUS
INFECTIONS MAY NOT BE GIVEN
IMMUNITY TO THESE NEW VARIANTS.
THE NOVA VAX TRIAL SHOWED PEOPLE
GETTING COVID-19 AGAIN MANY HAD
ACTUALLY HAD A PRIOR INFECTION
WITH THE PRECEDING.
JEDEDIAH: I HATE TO INTERRUPT
YOU UNFORTUNATELY WE WILL HAVE
TO WRAP TODAY.
I APPRECIATE IT.
BUT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE YOU
BACK TO EXPAND ON, THIS OKAY?
NO WORRIES.